il savoure une première victoire en
entonnant quelques notes
[Applaudissements]
et locataires de la résidence mont
carmel viennent d'obtenir une ordonnance
de la cour supérieure qui permet de
garder pour le moment la vocation de
leur immeuble qui est une résidence
privée pour aînés c'est une belle
victoire nicole jeter 79 ans porte la
cause avec 56 autres résidents cette
décision du juge en jeu nous il est
devant un énorme à un mouvement
extraordinaire de ses libertés le 31
janvier dernier ils ont eu toute une
surprise quand ils ont reçu un avis
d'éviction leur disant que l'immeuble
sera transformé en complexe locatif
multigénérationnel alors que le nouveau
propriétaire s'était engagé à respecter
sa vocation actuelle de résidences pour
aînés il ya des gens en recevant la vie
des fictions qui ont fait des avc il ya
eu un avc oui j'ai eu ce même la
confirmation ce matin par l infirmière
et locataires on en met une première
manche mais constate avec regret une
diminution des services il n'y a plus de
salon coiffure ni de dépanneurs anciens
déménagement là dans les temps où je
suis
j'ai ce que je veux c'est que nous
nos droits soient respectés et la
direction s'est faite discrète lors de
notre passage la député de québec
solidaire a commenté la sphère en disant
que se mobiliser et faire reconnaître
ses droits ça n'a pas d'âge on en a la
preuve aujourd'hui on est fier de ce
qu'on a fait et puis je trouve que ne
serait-ce que ça ça vaut lui la peine de
se tenir debout plusieurs locataires
d'un immeuble qui sont presse patrick au
contenu et aux pattes et qui sont je
pense très heureux d'avoir une décision
d'un travail fait en sorte que
maintenant le propre et la régulation de
maintenir la certification
l'exploitation et à tout le moins
jusqu'au 19 septembre prochain le 19
septembre c'est le moment où la cour va
entendre les parties afin de déterminer
si le tribunal compétent pour entendre
la sphère et le tribunal administratif
du logement ou la cour supérieure en
attendant les résidents eux gardent le
cap il ses ministres à françois radio
canada montréal